[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans un univers où ils sont tous
malveillants où il se dit des horreurs
elle l a été constante du début à la fin
l âge n est sûre personne comme elle a
toujours été adorable je ne donne jamais
mais l'émission est maintenant si elle
était géniale cette fille jean miche ans
franchement ça reste un programme très
familiale a pas beaucoup la télévision
bae programme contre les épreuves
contrairement à ce qu'il dit mais tu es
là toujours des nouvelles c'était la
première fois qu'il la faisait celles
qui restent parce que c'est des grands
classiques on a envie de revoir comme le
poteau et cetera au parcours du
combattant
on a envie de les voir et les cadres et
du candidat vieux barbon sur le wiki on
s'attache au live il ya tout il ya la
stratégie d'émotion photo dr alors c'est
une super épreuve mais ça n'a aucun
intérêt c'est à lui de rester 32 35
minutes devant devant deux personnes
debout sur un poteau voit toutes choses
bien deux heures sous une toile
[Applaudissements]
auj
je sens ma mère peut se tenir
[Applaudissements]
palace
la malaise du budo joue d'ailleurs je te
jure en poussette et quant à 10 le coup
d'état dire ouais je me suis dit bon il
va y avoir une nova mais lui ne savait
pas pourquoi de plus google réalise
jamais fait deux heures ça pleure je
pleure mais je garderai le plan du fou
ce mec est fou chantant décoller
aujourd'hui que ça va mais on attend
qu'on est là mais vraiment natal pour
new york il faudrait